one of the best places to engage in political
discussions with other viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show is the David Pakman
show subreddit.
I am a regular on the subreddit. I am in there
all the time mixing it up with people. So
it was producer Pat. You can find it at David
pacman.com/reddit. That's r e d d I t. Couple
of interesting posts I want to talk about.
Um, there was an inquiry about whether it
would be difficult for me to transition over
to twitch, twitch, a live streaming platform
that is huge. twitch.tv mostly or at least
significantly for video game streaming, which
I don't really play. Uh, but I have been thinking
about what to do on twitch and I actually
have made an account and I am going to do
a, a premiere stream on twitch sometimes soon.
I don't exactly know what to do. I had the
idea of since the only thing close to a game
that I plays chess, I could live stream some
chess playing play against members of the
audience if they want, take questions and
just sort of hang out.
And if someone reached out and said, you know,
you didn't really build an audience playing
chess, you build an audience talking about
politics. So that might be a mistake to do
on twitch. So I don't know exactly what I
would do on twitch. Twitch has this requirement
if you want to monetize your content that
the content has to be unique to twitch or
at least initially only on twitch, you can
later upload it to youtube if you want, but
it has to first be on twitch if you want to
monetize it. So just uploading our youtube
content to twitch is not, I don't even know
if it's possible, but, uh, it's not something
that, uh, we should be doing. Uh, same thing
with simultaneously streaming to twitch, twitch
and youtube. So I'm open to ideas. Let me
know what you think would be interesting for
me to do on twitch.
Um, I'm on twitch. I believe it's just David
Pacman and you can follow me there in advance
of a, this extraordinarily compelling premiere
that, um, has yet, uh, as, as of yet not been
scheduled, but more importantly, let me know
what I could be doing on twitch that would
be different than what we're doing on our
other platforms. Interesting. And maybe start
to generate an audience there also from the
David Pakman show, sub reddit White House
social media summit to snub a tech giants,
host conservative personalities. Yeah, I was
talking to Tim pool yesterday who I know that
despite our political disagreements, it may
come as a shock that we actually are in touch,
uh, privately. But, uh, we've always actually
had a good relationship regardless of our
political disagreements. I was talking to
him, Tim Pool is invited and it's basically
all right wingers. And I said to him, Tim,
it would be really amazing if you were able
to get on video telling Trump there really
should be some left wingers here because they're
actually also being affected by all of the
issues that we're talking about.
And I told them extra points, if you mentioned
my name to Trump, I don't actually think that
he's going to do it. Maybe by the time you
watch this clip, we will know whether anything
like that happened. But uh, yeah, I mean the,
the, the selection of people that were invited,
including some, I think there was one person
invited to this summit who has 3000 followers
on Twitter, if I recall correctly. If I'm
wrong, I apologize. But I believe that that's
what I saw. And like Google and Facebook weren't
even invited and obviously no progressive,
uh, was invited who has an independent online
platform. So I don't know whether any big
problems are going to be solved at this tech
summit, but I d do look forward to seeing
a video of it which may be available by the
time you listen to me talk about this.
Join the sub reddit more than 11,000 of our
viewers and listeners now on the subreddit@davidpacman.com
slash red dit. The reddit is not a throwaway.
Okay. The reddit regularly contributes content
to the show. I'm personally on the subreddit.
I am paying attention to what's going on there.
So please, uh, please participate.